à kiev retrouver justement notre envoyé
spécial clovis casali on le président
ukrainien estime d'ailleurs que devrait
que la russie devrait parler à l'ukraine
tôt ou tard pour mettre fin aux combats
quelle est la situation à la mi-journée
en ce moment
mais je peux vous dire qu'ici à kiev
personne n'imagine une fin des combats
pour tout de suite selon des témoignages
qu'on vient de recueillir trois missiles
auraient atterri tout près du ministère
de la défense ukrainien qui se trouve à
un kilomètre 5 d'où je me trouve ici en
plein centre de la capitale kiev trois
missiles dont qui aurait atterri à côté
à du ministère de la défense en tout cas
les combattants rue se rapproche du
centre de la ville on a il ya des
témoignages et des confirmations de
combat des échanges de tirs nourris avec
aussi des explosions dans le quartier
doble en ski qui est juste en bordure de
kiev certains considèrent d'ailleurs
comme un quartier de kiev des échanges
de tirs avec des hélicoptères russes qui
auraient frappé et qui auraient déposé
des troupes c'est ce qui se dit en tout
cas ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la situation est extrêmement tendue ici
à kiev et comme dans toute l'ukraine
d'ailleurs et la population reste terrée
chez elle depuis ce matin des sirènes
retentissent pour parler de possibles
bombardements pour prévenir à des
bombardements et pour inviter intimé
l'ordre la population de rentrer chez
elle alors regardez les rues sont quasi
vides étonnante scène à kiev et c'est
pourtant les scènes que l'on voit depuis
quelques jours ici avec abdallah malka
oui et rob parsons une situation tendue
de nombreux habitants ont déjà quitté la
ville la plupart des hôtels ont été
évacuées et je peux vous dire que la
nuit a été courte pour tout le monde ici
à kiev alors volodymyr zelensky clovis
salue l'héroïsme de son peuple l'armée
ukrainienne peut-elle résister ou
contre-attaqué en at elle les moyens
alors c'est une question très difficile
à laquelle répondre judith c'est
compliqué ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'ici à kiev il y a des forces du
chrétienne qui patrouillent on a vu des
soldats en armes et c'était plutôt des
miliciens ou peut-être s'efforce
volontaires ces réservistes que
justement le président zelensky a appelé
à prendre les armes et leur a demandé de
venir patrouiller en ville et de venir
défendre la capitale contre
l'envahisseur russe on en a rencontré
certains de ses réservistes ces derniers
jours qu'ils nous disaient qu'il était
hors de question pour eux de quitter la
capitale qu'ils étaient là pour défendre
leur patrie ukrainienne que le pays
était en danger et qu'il devait donc se
mobiliser on parle d'ukrainiens jusqu'à
l'âge de 60 ans vous imaginez qu'ils
pourraient prendre les armes certains
ont peut-être connu le combat dans l'est
du pays d'autres certainement pas ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il va falloir des
munitions aux ukrainiens ils ne feront
pas le poids face aux hommes russes face
aux soldats russes qui sont venus
envahir un peu partout le pays avec ses
opérations coordonnées menées à par
vladimir poutine vous avez peut-être vu
derrière moi des gens qui viennent de
passer avec des sacs à dos des jeunes
qui sont en train soit de se préparer il
semblerait qu'ils se préparent à quitter
qui a fait bien il ya eu beaucoup de
gens qui ont quitté kiev ces derniers
jours encore aujourd'hui certains de nos
collègues nous parler de
d'embouteillages monstres à la sortie de
la ville compliqué de partir et c'est
encore pire ces derniers jours il y
avait aussi des files d'attentes devant
les stations essence ici à kiev des gens
qui étaient prêts à attendre une heure
même plus pour remplir leurs jerrycans
on n'a pas pu aller voir aujourd'hui
quelle était la situation à cause des
bombardements à cause des opérations
russes qui se rapproche grandement du
centre de kiev les russes qui forcément
veulent viser des des objectifs de choix
des objectifs politiques je vous parlais
tout à l'heure peut-être du ministère de
la défense qui aurait été visé par les
hommes russes en tout cas la crainte ici
à kiev c'est que les russes arrivent en
nombre et avec force surtout à kiev